las calles convertidas en torrentes
vehículos sumergidos en la fuerte lluvia
en malawi el ciclón Freddy ha golpeado
de nuevo causando inundaciones y grandes
deslizamientos de Tierra según la
oficina de desastres del país cerca de
un centenar de personas murieron y
decenas más resultaron heridas o
desaparecieron también en mozambique el
ciclón arrasó toda su paso con Vientos
de 150 kilómetros por hora las
carreteras el agua y la electricidad
quedaron cortadas en algunos lugares
100.000 usuarios están sin electricidad
es caótico tendré que buscar la manera
de cubrir mi casa con planchas de zinc
para poder sobrevivir
el ciclón lleva 35 días azotando el sur
de África está por convertirse en el más
largo de la historia y quizás también en
el más impredecible
se formó frente a las costas de
Australia y cruzó el océano Índico antes
de golpear Madagascar y mozambique a
finales de febrero también allí hubo
varios muertos y miles de desplazados
desde hace una semana vuelve a afectar a
estas dos zonas
la característica los notable es que en
el mar ha recuperado el calor la humedad
y Una atmósfera favorable ha podido
recuperar su intensidad y convertirse en
un ciclón importante
según las previsiones se espera que el
ciclón se desplace hacia el mar durante
la semana y finalmente se debilite